et pour le guide suprême iranien les
inimitiés des états unis à l'égard de
l'iran ne cesseront pas avec le départ
de donald trump l'ayatollah ali khamenei
s'est adressé aux responsables iraniens
et à la famille du général qasem
soleimani tué en janvier par une frappe
aérienne américaine près de l'aéroport
international de bagdad en irak
la fille de ce dernier s'est exprimé
dans une interview de going under ground
est pour elle aussi 30 biden a
difference on écoute nazis d'aïn abessa
non il n'y a pas de différence entre bay
denis trump c'est la même personne et
ils suivent la même politique
il n'y aucune différence entre eux
jambes holder trump a ordonné le meurtre
de mon père mais byden a soutenu cela
donc il n'ya pas de différence
ils ont la même façon de penser les
suive la même voie
il sous une seule et même personne
ali bagheri gérer dit hayden était
d'accord avec obama quand ils ont créé
l'état islamique
quelle est la différence entre trump
réveil dès qu'est ce qui va changer
c'est la même personne le même esprit il
n'y a aucune référence pour je veux dire
joe boyd ne peut pas nous rendre mon
père est il capable de le faire
il ne peut pas sauter 2 alors le
problème que nous avons avec l'amérique
masse et leur politique cela ne changera
pas réussi c'est la même personne le
même esprit la mairie voix et chacun
d'entre eux est pire que le droit